Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
La domanda me l'ha posta innanzitutto TEDx,
perché fino ad ora non mi ero mai considerata propriamente attivista.
C'è un dato oggettivo: sono impegnata in Action Aid
ormai da quasi una decina di anni, quindi quando ho ricevuto questo invito
per prima cosa mi sono chiesta: ”Ma in che senso sono attivista?
Che cosa significa, per me?” E le risposte le ho trovate,
per l'appunto, in questa organizzazione straordinaria,
internazionale, della quale ho potuto partecipare.
Ci sono due ragioni, sostanzialmente,
per le quali mi riconosco in Action Aid e rispetto a cui
riesco poi a considerarmi attivista.
La prima ragione riguarda una trasformazione
(a mio avviso straordinaria, è stata davvero una rivoluzione culturale,
in questo settore) che Action Aid ha fatto.
Tradizionalmente, Action Aid nasce come una charity,
come ce ne sono molte altre. Nasce a Londra,
raccoglie fondi nel nord del mondo, e usa questi soldi
per fornire beni e servizi alle comunità povere,
ed escluse ed emarginate, nel sud del mondo.
Questa immagine che potete vedere, per l'appunto,
rappresenta questo approccio molto tradizionale.
A un certo punto Action Aid si è resa conto
che questo tipo di approccio era inefficace, c'era la necessità di aprirsi,
mettersi in ascolto di quelle persone che si voleva, per l'appunto, aiutare.
Che c'era qualcosa di paternalistico nel pensare che, da Londra,
fosse possibile decidere di cosa ci fosse bisogno, appunto,
a Delhi piuttosto che in Africa o nell'America Latina,
dove pure l'organizzazione opera. Oggi, Action Aid è una federazione.
In ogni paese in cui siamo presenti, ci siamo dotati di una struttura
con uno staff locale, e ci siamo dotati, o ci stiamo dotando,
di una struttura di governance (quindi di un'assemblea e di un consiglio)
composta da persone che vivono in quello stesso paese.
I rappresentanti di ciascun paese confluiscono poi
in un'assemblea internazionale, e concorrono insieme
a decidere quali siano le priorità, quali siano le strategie,
quali gli strumenti migliori, per perseguire la missione di Action Aid,
ovvero appunto, come dicevo, combattere la povertà,
l'ingiustizia e l'esclusione sociale. Oggi, Action Aid è questo:
questa immagine è stata scattata a Johannesburg, all'inizio di quest'anno.
Centoventi persone, che provenivano da tutto il mondo,
hanno insieme posto le basi per quello che sarà
la nuova strategia di Action Aid per i prossimi 5 anni.
Per me, individualmente, la cosa fondamentale che ho imparato,
e nella quale mi riconosco, di Action Aid, è il fatto
che ci si deve aprire all'esperienza, agli sguardi
e alla concezione del mondo e ai bisogni delle altre persone,
e che da soli si va poco lontano. C'è una seconda
(il secondo insegnamento generale che ho appreso da Action Aid)
e che riguarda i valori, il fatto che abbiamo bisogno di valori che siano,
che in qualche modo ci trascendano,
che trascendano i nostri interessi particolari.
Sembra una banalità, ma riuscire a sentire, a percepire
questa cosa profondamente, e a metterla in pratica,
e ad alimentarla tutti i giorni credo che sia una cosa particolarmente importante.
A questo riguardo vorrei citare un filosofo israeliano, che si chiama Avishai Margalit
(non fa parte direttamente, diciamo, del background culturale di Action Aid
ma credo che sia particolarmente pertinente)
Margalit è entrato un po' di anni fa, con un libro che si chiama “La società decente”,
su un dibattito molto classico della filosofia, che è quello della società giusta.
Si è chiesto, Avishai Margalit: che cos'è una società giusta?
Una società giusta è praticamente impossibile da definire in maniera efficace.
Molto meglio, suggerisce Margalit, cercare di proporsi di costruire una società decente.
E una società decente (in inglese suona meglio, “a decent society”)
è una società che non umilia i propri cittadini.
Ecco: io credo che questo sia un indirizzo estremamente efficace, molto tagliente,
per orientare le politiche pubbliche e anche, tutto sommato, i nostri comportamenti individuali.
In Action Aid, questo, per così dire, è tradotto in: trasformare profondamente
il proprio modo di operare. Se un tempo Action Aid andava,
come fanno molte organizzazioni, e in minima parte, in casi di grande emergenza,
fa ancora anche Action Aid (fornire beni e servizi dove c'era bisogno, per l'appunto,
di beni e servizi), questa visione oggi è superata. Non si opera più in questo modo,
perché ci si è resi conto che così facendo si andava a ledere, a interferire
con quello che dovrebbe essere un rapporto stretto, empatico tra cittadinanza e istituzioni.
Al contrario, oggi Action Aid cerca di lavorare, di fare leva soprattutto su due cose:
da un lato i diritti delle persone, la promozione dei diritti;
dall'altro, l'accountability, che significa poi, concretamente, la costruzione di regole
in maniera partecipata e trasparente ed il rispetto di queste regole,
e l'impegno a rendere conto del proprio operato.
Oggi, peraltro, l'accountability è proprio al centro della strategia di Action Aid Italia,
che è stata da poco lanciata, in parallelo con quella internazionale.
Ma oggi, vi volevo parlare per l'appunto anche dell'Italia,
di quello che io sento essere davvero un'urgenza molto forte nostra.
E questo riguarda quello che a mio avviso è (e non è soltanto una percezione mia),
ma è una progressiva frammentazione, molto marcata, della nostra società.
In cui ci si contrasta, si confligge costantemente, ci si contrappone,
senza che vi sia modo di trovare uno spazio in cui trovarsi, discutere, costruire insieme.
Abbiamo conflitti a livello politico, su cui è inutile aggiungere altro,
abbiamo conflitti a livello generazionale, abbiamo conflitti a livello di interessi diversi.
E abbiamo completamente perso di vista il fatto che abbiamo bisogno, invece,
di un terreno comune da cui partire. Vorrei farvi notare che in tutto questo
c'è un ulteriore elemento che secondo me oggi rende la situazione ancora più problematica, e più difficile.
E che riguarda il modo in cui noi ci informiamo,
i luoghi dove noi prioritariamente andiamo a cercare le informazioni.
Questo modo in cui oggi ci informiamo, il modo e la quantità straordinaria di informazioni
di cui possiamo disporre oggi, fa sì che ciascuno di noi, molto più di quanto non fosse in passato,
si costruisca un proprio background culturale, e che sia molto difficile invece
rintracciare una sorta di base comune culturale tra noi italiani, per esempio.
È una grande ricchezza, una straordinaria risorsa, però dobbiamo comunque porci il problema
di dove troveremo i fondamenti per un territorio comune, per un linguaggio comune.
Considerate oltretutto che i luoghi in cui prioritariamente noi ci informiamo
(che è Internet, oggi, sempre di più) - anche in questi territori, oggi,
troviamo dei meccanismi che in maniera molto subdola, senza che noi ce ne accorgiamo,
favoriscono questa frammentazione. Se prendete Facebook, se prendete Google
e tanti altri colossi della gestione dell'informazione, quello che sta succedendo è
che questi soggetti stanno filtrando l'informazione per noi, in modo tale da personalizzarla,
da essere più efficienti, nel mondo in cui ci forniscono l'informazione.
Personalizzare l'informazione vorrà dire che vi verrà fornita l'informazione che vi corrisponde,
che vi somiglia sempre di più, e che tutto quello che è diverso da voi
rischia di finire fuori dal vostro campo visivo: non lo percepite, e non ne siete neppure consapevoli.
Questo contribuisce, potenzialmente, a una spinta verso la creazione di isole di persone
che si ritrovano, si riconoscono e che però hanno poca contezza di quello che c'è al di fuori di loro.
Penso quindi che abbiamo un grandissimo bisogno di inventarci,
di trovare dei nuovi luoghi comuni: usiamo questa espressione che come al solito
viene impiegata in maniera così, un po' sprezzante.
Nuovi luoghi comuni quali possono essere? E che cosa devono essere, innanzitutto?
Devono essere dei luoghi in cui ciascuno di noi si senta a proprio agio ad esporre quello che è,
a manifestare la propria identità, i propri bisogni, i propri punti di vista.
Ma questo non è sufficiente: deve esserci anche una disponibilità all'ascolto,
un'apertura e una curiosità nei confronti di quello che c'è d'altro e di diverso da sé.
Quando ero a scuola ho avuto un insegnante molto brillante, un austriaco,
che aveva l'abitudine (insegnava Etica) e aveva l'abitudine di dividere la classe a metà,
prendere un tema bello controverso e dire a una parte della classe di sostenere una determinata tesi,
e all'altra metà della classe di sostenere la tesi esattamente opposta.
Questo a prescindere, completamente, dalle preferenze individuali.
In questo modo ciascuno di noi era portato, era costretto a distaccarsi,
almeno momentaneamente, dalle proprie credenze, dalle proprie preferenze,
e a prendere sul serio gli argomenti che erano sul tavolo.
Credo che ci sia un grandissimo bisogno di questo tipo di esercizio
(c'è bisogno di questo esercizio nelle scuole, ma probabilmente anche fuori)
e mi chiedevo se non fosse pensabile immaginare una sorta di piattaforma,
su Internet (perché Internet, nonostante quello che ho detto sopra,
rimane il luogo in cui confluiamo tutti e in cui le informazioni, a ben cercare,
ci sono, naturalmente): una piattaforma in cui fosse possibile ri-raccontarci,
e disegnare il paese Italia così come la vorremmo.
Se vogliamo, fino ad arrivare quasi a ridefinire, a ricostruire, passo per passo,
una sorta di Costituzione Italiana fatta in maniera, però, del tutto partecipata.
È un'idea assolutamente embrionale, per il momento, che ho voluto oggi condividere con voi,
che personalmente mi sembra utile ed interessante, in qualche modo,
a complemento del mio impegno in Action Aid.
Oggi Action Aid è impegnata soprattutto, in Italia, sui temi dell'accountability,
ma avendo ben presente che c'è una necessità di riportare una maggiore consapevolezza
sui valori di costruzione della percezione di quanto importante sia
avere un terreno comune nel quale ci si riconosca, tenuto insieme da valori comuni.
In questo gioco, che per il momento è pura speculazione, mi piacerebbe coinvolgere le scuole,
mi piacerebbe poter partire dai bambini delle scuole.
Chiedere a loro che tipo di paese vorrebbero che fosse l'Italia.
E chiedere poi ai ragazzi un po' più grandi di prendere queste idee, di elaborarle,
di affinarle, cosi andando progressivamente, da un lato a generare
una banca dati di materiali, di speculazione, di immaginario comune.
Un'esperienza diffusa tra molte persone – quante più persone possibile.
Il confronto, appunto, con persone “altro da sé” e progressivamente,
usando possibilmente strumenti come quelli di cui ci ha parlato questa mattina
Frieda Brioschi, cioè wiki, provando a tracciare di nuovo, ad affinare insomma
tutto questo materiale e a tracciare dei valori nei quali ci si possa riconoscere,
da una parte, e delle regole, dei modi poi per tradurre questi valori nella realtà.
Un gioco del tutto speculativo, che penso possa essere fatto in rete,
più difficilmente in altri ambiti, perché abbiamo bisogno di trovare un territorio neutro,
nel quale ci sia davvero la confidenza per svestirsi, almeno temporaneamente,
dei propri interessi personali, e per esporsi, senza sentire il rischio
del conflitto con l'altro, il rischio di essere subito aggrediti,
come purtroppo, sempre più spesso, succede.
Questo era il piccolo progetto, la piccola speculazione personale
che volevo condividere con voi oggi.
Forse il messaggio che mi preme di più lasciare è: immaginiamo dei luoghi comuni.
Credo che questo sia davvero urgente per tutti noi.
I modi possono essere tanti, e credo che ciascuno di noi possa trovarne
nella propria sfera privata o unendosi, aggregandosi ad altre persone, delle declinazioni proprie.
(Applausi)